usa today has just announced its women
of the year and assistant secretary of
health richard levine has made the list
you go girl
this is one small step for a man and one
giant leap backward for women
the message here in philadelphia in love
park is that trans rights are human
rights you have worth you have
tremendous worth just for who you are no
matter who you love no matter who you
are no matter what your gender identity
sexual orientation or anything else and
to be true to that
and then everything else will follow and
it highlights something which i truly
believe in which is the value of
diversity diversity is just so important
in our culture it's important for our
country for the world now say what you
will about mr levine
he certainly adds diversity to the list
of women of the year but his message
doesn't make a lot of sense
his message the whole headline of the
article in usa today is
be true to yourself
but transgenderism does precisely the
opposite of that it encourages people to
be dishonest with themselves
to lie to themselves and to everybody
else to pretend that reality is
different than it really is
mr levine may or may not be a nice guy
he might be a friendly neighbor he might
be a good cook i don't know
the only thing that i do know about
richard levine is that he is not true to
himself
our society is now so divorced from
truth
that we call men women we call abortion
health care we call criminals victims
richard levine is one very confused man
but what's our excuse i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from nosferatu and
friends
who says biden
shuts down pipeline construction
biden two years later don't blame me
that pipeline was two years away from
completion this is a great point this is
one of the
aspects of the whole keystone pipeline
debate that is least talked about one of
the democrat talking points is no you
can't blame high gas prices and rising
energy costs on us shutting down the
keystone pipeline that was two years
away from completion
two years is not a long time and two
years is priced into oil and gas prices
and if they just let the damn thing be
built we'd almost be finished with it by
now really really frustrating and then
we could just sit down and rest easy
when you want to sit down and rest easy
i would strongly recommend you check out
all form right now head on over to
allform.com
knowles you know helix makes these
phenomenal mattresses well they've left
the bedroom and started making sofas
they just launched a new company called
all form and they are already making the
greatest sofas ever they're phenomenal
what makes them so great well it's the
easiest way you can customize a sofa
using premium materials do you want
cloth do you want leather you can do
whatever really high quality stuff at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you pick the fabric the color the
color of the legs the sofa size the
shape you make sure it's the perfect fit
for your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
you can go all the way up to an eight
seat sectional so there's something for
everyone and you can start small and
then add on as your family and your home
grow
really really top quality you are not
going to see this quality for this price
anywhere else it's super easy assembly
it's brought directly to your door no
tools needed to find your perfect sofa
go to allforum.com knowles all form is
offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners allform.com
one one giant leap
back toward the most
ancient bizarre pagan occult ideologies
transgenderism that is what mr levine's
selection as one of the women of the
year
suggests women are having a really hard
go of it and the worst part is women
think
that all of the
damage that has been done to them in
society is actually some form of
progress i saw this just the other day
the other day was ruth bader ginsburg's
birthday the late supreme court justice
rbg
uh there there was a tweet that went
viral about rbg's birthday that really
epitomized i think
feminist delusion
this person said today would have been
ruth bader ginsburg's 89th birthday she
spent her life empowering women and now
we are a force to be reckoned with
now
you know before that justice lady who
was appointed in the 90s before women
not empowered women could do nothing
they were completely useless totally
oppressed and then after the early 1990s
after ruth bader ginsburg now they're
now they're so empowered that men are
taking all of their jobs
and when i say women's jobs i'm not
saying the jobs in the office places
that women have come to take on over the
years
i mean men have now taken the job of
being women even that is not available
to women anymore because the men have
taken it
what did ruth bader ginsburg do to help
women nothing you can't even say that
she broke the glass ceiling ruth bader
ginsburg wasn't even the first female
supreme court justice that was sandra
day o'connor appointed by ronald reagan
what did ruth bader ginsburg do she
voted with the court's liberals on a
bunch of cases and that's it and that's
all she did
the most interesting thing the woman did
in her life was be friends with antonin
scalia that was it
she did not change the position of women
moreover the position of women has not
improved
i i saw this tweet and some people
criticized it and they said what are you
talking about what did ruth bader
ginsburg do you know i think women were
a force to be reckoned with before the
90s
i think there have been pretty
impressive women threat history like i
don't know queen elizabeth the virgin
mary joan of arc marie curie for that
matter there have been a lot of women
right who have done things in this world
and
it didn't all begin with ruth bader
ginsburg so someone said well no michael
what you don't understand is
before they were applying this to ruth
ginsburg which didn't make sense but
let's just say before the last 50 or so
years
women didn't have lots of the rights
that they now enjoy rights such as and
i'm quoting one of the responses
the the right to divorce
the right to work
the right to access birth control and
abortion
now
none of those things are exactly right
first of all women always worked it's
true that now women have more
opportunities to go work in the widget
factory like men do women have the
wonderful right to go do spreadsheets
for some other guy and waste away their
lives that's true they do have that
right
girl power way to go
but what about these other rights
the right to to birth control women now
have the right
for men to use them for sex and throw
them away like they're worthless they
have that right now ha ha that'll show
you patriarchy women have the right to
divorce and have their husbands leave
them without any consequences or
accountability whatsoever yeah all right
girl power women have the right to kill
their children yes women that'll that'll
empower you that'll make you feel good
about yourself that will left it's not a
right at all there's no right to do that
whatsoever
i take social science with a grain of
salt but i will cite the statistics when
they back up my opinion okay i'll be
totally forthright about that i think
most social science is bogus and
unreliable but i am more than happy to
cite the left's own statistics when it
serves my purpose and on the question of
female happiness the statistics are very
clear since second wave feminism since
all of these rights quote unquote came
into place that
all of these feminists are quoting women
have become less happy both relative to
men and in absolute terms so it's not
even just like everyone got less happy
men got less happy too sure
but even relative to men women got much
less happy and now women aren't even
allowed to be women now men are allowed
to be women and the category of women is
no longer said to exist women lost their
bathrooms women lost their locker rooms
women lost their sport sports leagues
women have lost
pretty much everything all in the name
of progress if that's progress if that's
achievement i think maybe you've got to
check your premises
this issue here of abortion as some
right it's now sort of the sacrament of
the left it's the most sacred quote
unquote right on the left it's why they
go so crazy every time roe versus wade
is threatened
it it does not lead to human flourishing
obviously it kills the baby but it's
really bad for women too
evan rachel wood
showed me this the actress evan rachel
wood is in this new documentary about
marilyn manson she dated marilyn manson
the most famous satanist in america and
it turns out he's apparently not a great
guy
you might be shocked by that turns out
everyone's parents in the 1990s was
right the the really famous satanist is
kind of a weirdo and and kind of cruel
and kind of sadistic and
although their
romantic relationship was consensual
sort of
he still subjected this young actress to
all sorts of terrible things and one of
the one of the things that she alleges
he subjected her to was he
would not
use
a condom he would not let her take the
birth control pill
she became pregnant and he pressured her
to go get an abortion
this
evan rachel wood cites as one of the
most traumatic events in her life
but why is it traumatic i thought this
was a great right to be celebrated i
thought this was the most important
sacred constitutional right that we all
need to stand up for
well evan rachel wood tries to square
that circle she says i obviously believe
in a woman's right to choose but that
doesn't mean it wasn't devastating
and after she got the abortion she was
so depressed she became suicidal and she
actually tried to kill herself i have no
doubt that that's true
i know women i know a number of women
who have had abortions and it has really
really messed them up
why
why that's the next question that evan
rachel wood has to ask herself i believe
in a woman's right to choose but i was
devastated
why were you devastated
because
you killed your child because it's so
obviously wrong that no amount of
ideology can convince you otherwise no
amount of ideology can suppress that
nagging voice which is your conscience
which is telling you that you've done
something really awful now
there is redemption there is a way out
of this okay there is
the possibility of salvation
but you've got to acknowledge that what
you did was wrong and she seems
unwilling to do that she says i
obviously believe in a woman's right to
jews why do you believe in that
it made you suicidal because of this
so-called right you tried to kill
yourself because you exercised that
right maybe it's not a right
maybe
maybe you were sold a bill of goods
by
an ideology that has made you miserable
has made your culture coarser and has
made your country so confused that it
can no longer tell the difference
between men and women
we've got to protect our communities
including the most local community the
household which is why you got to check
out ring right now go to ring.com
knowles you know about rings video
doorbell i've told you about it for
years you know about ring alarm i've
even mentioned ring alarm this
award-winning security system with
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe
amazing system where you can easily
install it yourself well
you might not know that recently i've
gone pro
i have gone pro with ring alarm pro ring
alarm pro
is just the next level it is the top
shelf cnet calls ring alarm pro a giant
leap for home security after using it
you're going to see exactly what we're
talking about ring alarm pro helps
protect the entire home and the wi-fi it
runs on with ring alarm pro ring
combined a home security system and a
wi-fi router
so it protects your home and your
network your physical world your virtual
world i i can't recommend this enough i
love ring it makes me feel more secure
now it makes me feel more secure
digitally as well as physically for my
family when i'm on the road when we're
all on the road protects the home from
freeze fire flood it's just tremendous
go learn more at ring.com
knowles do not wait ring.com
knowles
speaking of violence
we have an update from
criminal justice reform you know i've
been doing these sort of regular updates
on criminal justice reform because we
are told the the worst problem in
america is over incarceration and the
criminals are the real victims and we've
got to focus on what we as a society
have done to force these people to
commit these crimes so i want to see how
this is going because what we were told
was
if we go softer on the criminals and we
let them out of prison and we let them
get away with their crimes then things
will improve the crime rate will go down
we'll all live in harmony we'll sing
kumbaya and play in drum circles
together so has that happened uh no
in one of the latest attacks a brutal
and unprovoked attack a
young man relatively young man 40 year
old man was caught on surveillance
footage at a seattle subway station
grabbing a 62-year-old woman kim hayes
and throwing her down a flight of cement
steps
this was at the chinatown international
district station
hayes this 62 year old woman is a nurse
she's worked at a nurse for a long time
she was going in to this hospital to
work and then around noon time so broad
daylight right right at lunch this guy
comes up flings her down a flight of
cement stairs
well how could we have predicted this
look michael crime happens okay you're
not gonna you sound just as utopian as
the left there's no way to prevent all
crime that's true but i think i could
have predicted this one because this guy
alexander j has been convicted
22 times
of crimes in washington state and
california
and it wasn't insider trading okay we're
not talking about white-collar crimes
here we're talking about violent crimes
he was convicted of burglary theft
selling stolen property drug possession
auto theft multiple counts of domestic
violence
well michael maybe that was all in his
past don't you think people deserve a
second chance
i believe in second chances i don't
believe in 20 second chances
but maybe it was a long time ago maybe
he paid his debt to society oh no it was
just last year
he was just last year convicted of a
residential burglary
he's been issued more than 15 bench
warrants since 2016
by washington courts and he failed to
attend his court hearings
this
guy
should not be allowed in society
forget after the 22nd offense the 21st
after the third offense what do they say
in baseball one
two twenty two strikes you're out no
three strikes you're out
if this guy's gonna keep committing all
of these offenses at the very least he
has to be locked away forever from
society at the very least
that's the that's the most moderate
punishment i could imagine
it's not good for him he's out there
doing horrible things to other people
and to himself he's not living a
flourishing life
he's harming himself his soul probably
his body and for what he's going to end
up back in jail they're probably going
to let him out and he's going to go
through another 60 year old woman down
the stairs
criminal just there it is there's
there's our over-incarceration problem
there are these poor beleaguered
criminals our problem we're just too
tough on these guys he never had a
chance no the 62 year old woman never
had a chance because you let these
animals run around society after 22
prior convictions it's not it's not just
one or two incidences we've got a guy in
yonkers
a guy in yonkers new york that's a town
just north of new york city guy in
yonkers
here's the new york times story from
this attack up in yonkers man hit woman
in the head 125 times because she was
asian officials say
67 67 year old woman wearing a white
face mask and dark hooded jacket and
pushing a shopping cart enters an
apartment building in yonkers new york
as she moves to unlock the door a man
comes up behind her and hits her in the
head with a roundhouse right hand the
force of the blow knocks the woman to
the ground as she lies there her
attacker bends down and pummels her
repeatedly with both hands for the next
minute more than 125 blows altogether he
then stomps on her seven times and spits
on her before walking away this is one
of the most appalling attacks i have
ever seen says john j muller the yonkers
police commissioner
to be a helpless woman is despicable
targon here because of his race makes it
more so absolutely right so this guy was
just a totally unpredictable
one-off attack right there was nothing
we could have possibly done to stop this
crime happens and oh no he had 14
previous arrests half of them on felony
charges according to the yonkers police
convicted of assault in 2011 sentenced
to just over three years in prison
released on parole after two and a half
because he's such a good guy
uh then he was released in october 2013
according to state prison records
and then he just keeps committing crimes
why was this animal let out of prison
because of compassion because he's the
real victim and the woman who almost got
murdered by this savage she's you know
she's just kind of part of the system
the institution the society and boy
didn't that society fail this poor man
gosh we got to do something about all
this over-incarceration
this leads
to not just bad outcomes for the victims
and for the individual at least about
outcomes for the society for the whole
community i think of what's one of the
worst towns in america right now
san francisco
and the crazy part about that is in san
francisco right now
the city
which is falling into just mayhem and
drugs everywhere human feces on the
street the cost of living is impossible
still somehow san francisco is
boycotting
the rest of the united states
what does that even mean i saw the
headline i said i don't even know what
that means
well there was a march 4th memo that
went out from the city administrator
carmen chu that shows that san francisco
will not enter into contracts with
businesses
headquartered in most of the united
states
that includes 28 states they won't do
this
because those states have what san
francisco deems to be
anti-lgbt laws and by anti-lgbt laws
sometimes that just means they won't let
dudes go into the little girl's locker
room but because of these laws
san francisco is boycotting the states
official travel to those states is
forbidden now i bet official travel to
african countries that are middle
eastern countries that throw
gay guys off of rooftops i bet that
that's not officially prohibited in any
of the state laws but traveling to i
don't know georgia
traveling to actually some traveling to
nevada traveling to new hampshire north
carolina wisconsin prohibited if you're
in san francisco
they can't ink these deals
countries cannot behave like this
okay this is
this is not
i guess this is the conclusion of
radical individualism because some
people will say well san francisco can
do whatever san francisco wants but i
don't believe that san francisco is a
city in the united states and if you're
a city if you're a state in the united
states you can't just boycott the rest
of the united states then you don't have
a country
okay we've got to work together we have
to have some things in common we've got
to work toward the carbon good that's
what a republic is as you hold things in
common and you work to better those
things you work to better the whole
society by working on your common good
real countries don't behave like this
but real countries know the difference
between men and women so we are pretty
far through the look at class
so is there any hope
is there any hope that we can have some
standards that we all agree on i
believe it's possible
representative thomas massey great gop
representative and 16 other house
republicans
are suing the cdc over its mask mandate
on flights you know the the libs want to
convince you that covid is over but it's
not really over
they've kept their emergency national
emergency authorization they've kept the
masks on flights they're keeping the
ability to spin this thing up just after
the midterm elections so 17 gop members
led by thomas massey are suing the cdc
and they're making two claims they say
first none of the statutes or
regulations cited by the cdc for the
authority to mandate that individuals
wear masks on commercial airlines
conveyances and transportation hubs
permit the cdc
to implement
or enforce this mandate so
none of the laws
that the cdc is citing as giving them
this power actually gives them this
power and then two
massey says even if congress had granted
the cdc the authority to promulgate the
mass mandate the granting of this
authority would violate a principle
known as the non-delegation doctrine so
he's saying even if the cdc could cite
laws the congress doesn't have the right
to outsource to the cdc a rule requiring
you all to muzzle yourselves every time
you go on public transit
i don't know the legal arguments for or
against his point on the non-delegation
doctrine but his first point seems
absolutely clear to me the cdc simply
does not have these rights
and yet that's what they're citing the
only way that we are ever going to get
back to a more
to a more coherent kind of country
is if we take this power back they're
not going to give it voluntarily you
actually have the president of the
united states right now he had a little
bit of a faux pas
he was speaking the other day and he
said that the
the husband of the first lady has
coveted
i was going to say
look at this stage but that's enough too
look at the stage
but there's been a little change in the
arrangement who's on the stage because
of
the first lady's husband uh contracting
covet but uh look at this room and what
you see
that's right
she's fine
it's me
that's not together
the second lady the first gentleman
how about that
anyway
ha ha the husband of the first lady
that's you that's you you old pudding
head it's uh huh oh right who's the who
am i thinking
oh the vice president her
husband
i don't know what's going on uh
one is it any surprise that vladimir
putin and our enemies around the world
are attacking that this guy doesn't know
what end is up he doesn't even know who
he is
but two they're gonna keep using kovid
they're gonna keep doing it we're
they're telling us kovid's over don't
worry we're not gonna wear the mask
we're not gonna do this and he says oh
we're a little social distanced here
because someone who's related to someone
in the administration has coveted
they are champing at the bit to use this
covid stuff again
they're just trying to get through the
midterms do not let them this is a once
in a generation chance to take away the
power
seized by parts of the government take
it back for the people restore our
american way of life do not let that
chance pass you by right protect
yourself protect your identity your
national and personal identity with
lifelock do not wait a minute right now
go to lifelock.com
knowles the tax filing deadline is right
around the corner with it brings irs
scammers looking to steal your money and
your personal information the most
common scams take place on the phone or
via email be smart do not give
information out or send money to anyone
over the phone
always ask for everything in writing and
only interact with websites that end
with dot gov it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
especially this time of year we're
putting information at risk on the
internet in an instant you won't even
know what happened a cyber criminal
could steal what's yours sometimes even
harm your finances and your credit good
thing there's lifelock lifelock helps
detect a wide range of identity threats
such as your social security number for
sale on the dark web you have access to
a dedicated restoration specialist if
you become a victim no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com knowles that is
lifelock.com knowles for 25
off we've also got something really
special we've been working on this for
months it is out now specifically today
to celebrate the two-year celebrate to
commemorate to bemoan the two-year
anniversary
of two weeks to slow the spread
uh this would be a documentary series
that we have worked on on dr fauci it's
called fouchy unmasked it is available
right now at the daily wire your humble
host leads you through the untold story
of dr fauci going all the way back to
the 1980s trying to answer this question
how did this guy attain power it's a
three-part series we're gonna drop
episode one today we'll drop episode two
tomorrow we're gonna drop episode three
on friday for a while i actually thought
ah they're gonna get fouchy out of the
news ever since i launched my public
health protection pledge ever since
fauci
had a lot of members of congress and
congressional candidates coming on
saying we're going to fire fauci this
year this could be a big campaign issue
you'll notice all of a sudden fauci just
disappeared he basically went into the
witness protection program democrats
realized he was really hurting their
numbers do not let this guy get away
with it we are not doing it just just
yesterday rand paul came out proposed an
amendment to get rid of dr fauci's
position we've got a congressman paul
gosar in the house of representatives
supporting
my pledge to say that dr fauci will have
his
salary zeroed out and that he will be
investigated
they're waiting to do this after
november
don't let them get away with it check
out the trailer
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020
dr fauci began to set national policy
that affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you wear a mask keep
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony fountain don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
go check out fauci unmasked it's
available exclusively at the daily wire
if you are not a member yet head on over
to dailywire.com subscribe to join also
dailywire's got its first book coming
out 12 seconds in the dark by sergeant
mattingly tells the true story of what
happened the night of the brianna taylor
shooting it's available now on amazon or
anywhere you buy books so go get your
copy today it is certain to sell out we
will be right back with a lot more
there is a story that has nothing to do
with russia has nothing to do with covid
has nothing to do with crime has nothing
to do with the economy and it is a story
that i love it's one of those rare
little glimmers of light and hope in our
culture and it's coming from ralph
lauren
the clothing maker
the sort of americana clothing maker
ralph lauren has just unveiled a fashion
line
for historically black colleges and
universities
i love this i think this is so
great
some people are going to hear that and
say oh this is going to be some woke
thing they're going to focus on identity
politics and it's black identity and
it's going to be the same old woke stuff
we've always heard that is not what is
going on here
the most
a jarring aspect i guess given the fact
that we live in this crazy identitarian
world the most jarring aspect of ralph
lauren's new clothing line for
historically black colleges and
universities
is that it's no different from ralph
lauren's clothing line
for any other college in university and
it's no different than all the other
clothes that he makes it's a kind of
traditional american slightly preppy
really put together clothing line you
can see all the photos they launched the
campaign
yesterday i absolutely
love this
because what this campaign is saying
is that
black people
are just like other people
they're not they're not some different
species that needs to be treated totally
differently you could see a lesser
fashion designer going in and say okay
we're gonna we're gonna
design clothing for black people and so
you know we're gonna design pants that
have to be worn at your ankles and we're
going to design really overpriced
sneakers and we're going to design i
don't know we're going to dress people
up like flavor flavor or something that
that's the real black experience and
that's that's what black people have to
dress like and the white people can
dress like white people and the black
people can dress like black people and
what ralph lauren has done is said no
you know
i'm going to design tasteful clothing
that is within the american tradition
that has been worn before we all went
crazy with identity politics that has
been worn by white people and black
people and all sorts of people i'm just
going to design
clothing according to a standard of
beauty
and class
and
dignity
and then i'm going to say this is the
clothing for black people as if to say
black people are
not only americans too
but black people are
people too they're capable of reason
they're capable of understanding
standards of beauty they're capable of
dressing in a way that is dignified and
uplifting because of course they are of
course that's true and everyone knew
this was the case until what 20 30 years
ago when the country went crazy with
political correctness and
multiculturalism and and now we're
living in a world where to pander to
black people nancy pelosi is wearing
kente scarves
and you know she's two seconds away from
you know
putting her fist in the air and doing a
performance of a black panther
it's
it's a very silly world that we're
living in it's very offensive to black
people it's not particularly good for
standards of beauty and dignity it's
certainly not good for the american
tradition which that kind of ideology
seeks to subvert and ralph lauren comes
in and he says okay you're ready for my
wild and crazy new style for black
people it's the same style i make for
everyone else because it looks good i
love this i totally love this
you've got
sweaters that have you know the
morehouse logo or spellman or tuskegee
you could replace those letters with an
h or y and a p and have it say harvard
yale or prince no they'd be the same
sweaters
they're saying hey guys
just dress nice look good recognize
we're we're all kind of part of this
tradition here
we've we've got a lot more in common and
we should elevate ourselves not a base
ourselves as lots of cultures have done
in recent decades absolutely great stuff
well done ralph lauren totally totally
love it speaking of racial issues
there is
a major racial racist hate crime
incident at a catholic high school in
rochester according to the newspapers
you see according to the newspapers
there was a graffiti incident at our
lady of mercy school for young women
last week
someone graffitied the n-word
on a bathroom wall
and on the back it said this school is
filled with a bunch of
n-words
not the words you know the people
get out
or else
and then man there were protests outside
of this school
people were furious and what happened
you already know what i don't even need
to tell you the conclusion of this story
sensible people people with two brain
cells to rub together who have not been
completely brainwashed by ideology will
look at that headline
they'll say oh it was a hoax
how dare you are you telling me racism
doesn't exist pretty much yeah i mean
you know the human heart is evil from
its beginning but beyond that base level
of original sin in a fallen world yeah
racism is fake it doesn't exist the only
legal racism is against whites and
asians in affirmative action and that
sort of legal discrimination but if
you're telling me that this is a country
run by klansmen where lynchings are
commonplace or exist at all where
crosses are burning on lawns i'm going
to tell you you're a complete lunatic
and none of that is happening whatsoever
and so when we see these alleged
incidents we just know 999
999 times out of a million they're going
to be fake and guess what happened guess
what happened
a student confessed to writing the
message
the student is remaining anonymous
she is being protected because she's a
minor but according to all of the
reports
it's a black student
we cover these shows we cover cover
these incidents all the time i have a
chapter of my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
number one national bestseller dedicated
to incidents such as this
why do these incidents happen
i don't think it happens necessarily
because these kids are malicious maybe
they are they might be malicious but
more i think they're deluded
i think they're trying to resolve a sort
of cognitive dissonance
they are told
that they live in a culture that hates
black people where whitey where the
patriarchy where the man keeps them down
and whereas lebron james says a black
person can't walk outside in america
without being hunted down
so that's what they're told that's what
they're taught
from their earliest ages
that's what all students are taught
and then
the reality does not conform to that
delusion
and so what do they do
do they change their delusions and
opinions
no they try to change reality
they go in and they say uh well huh i'm
not see people aren't taking racism
seriously here because there isn't any
of it so i know what i'll do i'll lie
i'll write i'll i'll create a hoax of a
racist incident and you know it won't be
honest in this case
but that lie will get to a greater truth
because i know because of my ideology i
know that these incidents are happening
all over the country and it's merely my
misfortune that they're not happening at
this school so i could show everybody
how horrible and racist america really
is so i'm just gonna
you know i'm gonna get the ball rolling
a little bit and just write this in and
that'll show this lie will show them the
truth
of course it doesn't because all of
these incidents that are allegedly
happening that are forming their
worldview
are hoaxes
i
you see it really most clearly in our
woman of the year according to usa today
the delusion says i am a woman
but the mirror says i am a man. the
reality says i am a man so what are you
going to do are you going to change your
disordered thinking are you going to
change your fantasy to bring it in line
with reality it would seem like that's
the easiest thing to do it's a lot
cheaper and less painful than undergoing
surgeries
no we're going to try to change reality
that is the power of ideology
you see it working on
young girls at a catholic school in
rochester you see it working on grown
men
who are somehow the assistant secretary
of health
now speaking of violence
speaking of real violence
russia has just fired a cruise missile
into western ukraine so you're seeing an
escalation of the war there it begins
with
troops around the border then an
incursion into the eastern regions then
you see the tanks rolling in but not a
ton of shelling then there's shelling
but they're trying to go after military
targets then they're shelling of
civilians now we've got cruise missiles
just flying in the russians
the russians can be absolute animals in
war
you see this throughout russian history
most recently probably in the second
world war
you're starting to see that again in
ukraine so russia fires the cruise
missiles and but what's most interesting
about this story
is that the cruise missiles were
apparently fired
not from within ukraine they were fired
from russian territory
why would russia do this
just to inflict destruction well they
could already do that they've already
got an army inside of ukraine why do
they need to fire a cruise missile from
russian airspace
they're doing that to put the final nail
in the coffin of a no-fly zone imposed
by the united states and nato
because the point of a no-fly zone
is that you've got american fighter jets
flying all ahead and if any russian
airplane is in ukrainian airspace the
americans or nato or whoever will shoot
down that airplane there can be no
incursions on ukrainian airspace
but russia doesn't need to send the
airplanes into ukraine russia can hit
ukraine even western ukraine where this
one hit
with missiles
from russia
so as the pentagon observes this means
that a no-fly zone over ukraine not only
is not prudent not only is there no
appetite for it
really among
the people broadly are supportive of it
i think it's three-quarters of americans
surveyed said they want a no-fly zone
but very few people know what a no-fly
zone really means very few people
realize that a no-fly zone means the
united states goes to war with russia
and so among
the people in power including
leftists and including
right-wing hardcore republicans
people say no we don't want a new flight
zone not only is it imprudent it's
ineffective
it won't do anything russia will just
start firing the cruise missiles all the
way to western ukraine from
russian airspace
they would seem to have
ukraine
outfoxed and the west outfoxed here
there's nothing really that the west is
going to do zelenski in ukraine has
already given up on ukraine joining nato
presumably he's given up on ukraine
joining the european union
nato has said we're not really going to
do anything here the united states won't
even let the polls send migs send
fighter jets to ukraine
we won't even let poland do that so
we're not going to do very much and now
rush is saying even if you wanted that
no-fly zone it's just not going to
happen
this is why
from the beginning i've said the
over-simplistic view of this war that
it's the question of strategy is one
between strength and weakness are we
going to be strong in ukraine or are we
going to be weak in ukraine it doesn't
i don't think that really holds up
we are extremely weak in ukraine right
now and
the the more strength we try to project
for instance inviting ukraine into nato
for instance inviting ukraine into the
european union for instance antagonizing
russia
it hasn't actually made us any stronger
it's only weakened our position in
ukraine
and now what are we now we haven't
really hurt vladimir putin all that much
our gas prices are through the roof he
still
is has by far the upper hand in ukraine
and nato looks impotent
we have these the way that we instituted
these sanctions hasn't really even hurt
putin all that much it's hurt russians
it's hurt americans
it's hurt europeans but it ha and now by
the way we're about to do a deal with
iran because joe biden just loves this
idea of doing a deal with iran and
putting them on the path to a nuclear
weapon so we're going to do the deal
with iran and and that's going to allow
russia to skirt through the sanctions
because russia is going to do business
with
iran
so iran signs on the dotted line for any
business russia wants to do and now all
of a sudden russia doesn't need to worry
about the sanctions it's just really
stupid policy and putin knew it and
biden was outmatched and that's just the
way that it goes it's very sad but it's
true russia's been doing this for years
outfoxing not just america but
specifically the american left the way
they've done it
specifically is by funding environmental
groups
in europe in the united states
why would russia fund environmental
groups because it is in russia's
national interest
to keep
russian oil and gas
a preeminent product in the world they
want to keep europe and the united
states hooked on russian oil and gas
but
they're not going to be able to do that
very effectively if if europe turns to
other sources of energy nuclear in
particular and if america starts
drilling baby drill and fracking and
pumping out
oil so what russia has done
and this is
confirmed not just by a lot of reporting
but
by intelligence taken with a grain of
salt is
they have funneled money into
non-governmental environmentalist
organizations
that have attacked those energy policies
and so
europe gives up its own energy america
stops drilling america just focuses on
the sun monster
and
russia wins and now you're in a position
where even joe biden says well yeah you
know look we are getting a lot of our
oil from russia we can try to turn it
off now then we've got to go to
venezuela or we've got to go to iran but
it's going to leave us
weaker
and the american left cheers this on is
it any wonder
that joe biden would get out flanked
this is a guy who
not only
can't remember the name of his policies
not only can't remember the name of his
staff not only can't remember the name
of his god you know you know the thing
he can't remember who he is himself
this is a guy who's been on the wrong
side not just of every domestic policy
issue in recent years but of every every
single foreign policy issue
he's the guy who applauded he said
a rising china is good for america it's
good for everyone hurrah hurrah hurrah
he was the guy who was so wrong on
russia that that president zlensky in
ukraine is blaming biden for the
invasion and this is being covered up by
the media but zolensky said the fact
that biden took the sanctions off
russia's oil pipeline is the reason that
russia invaded is it any wonder that
putin is out foxing him now
who could have done better i don't know
the last guy in office was pretty good
donald trump was able to govern for four
years and vladimir putin did not
encroach any further into other
countries putin invaded georgia under
bush he invaded ukraine under obama he
stopped during trump he just kind of
held off and then he invades ukraine
more clearly during joe biden
so
donald trump the total idiot incompetent
you know this child in charge we're
headed for world war iii he did a much
better job maintaining the world peace
than joe biden does and now
donald trump has another crazy idea he's
hitting the campaign trail again he's
got this crazy idea at a rally that the
left is pulling their hair out over
we will pass critical reforms making
every executive branch employee fireable
viable by the president of the united
states the deep state must and will be
brought to heal it's already happening
the deep state must and will be brought
to heal
does anyone disagree with that what's
the proposal is that people who work for
the executive branch
should be able to be fired by the head
of the executive branch
i bet a lot of people listening to that
rally
would be surprised that that's not the
case in america
what do you mean you're telling me the
president of the united states the
leader of the free world
can't fire people who work for him
even just regular old little bureaucrats
who work for we're not talking about the
secretary of state even we're just
talking about like the guy in the mail
room you can't fire that guy
no
and it's hard to fire that guy because
the progressives 100 years ago
constructed a federal bureaucracy
that basically just runs the country on
its own largely insulated from the
electoral politics from the will of the
people from the shifting winds in a
democracy
so trump says no i think we need to we
need to bring this bureaucracy back in
line
the left says this what a crazy maniac
that's how the country was run for most
most of our history at least half of our
history and it hasn't been run recently
which is why you see this phenomenon of
of the unit party
you know whoever gets elected for some
reason the national policy never changes
we just take out more and more debt we
invade more and more countries we
outsource more and more jobs we lose
more and more of our rights why is that
republican trump was able to impede it a
little bit more but still it just goes
on and on and on so trump is coming in
and he's running not even on an issue
like
oil not even on an issue like
immigration as he did the first time not
he's running on
an issue about the government he's
saying there's a structural problem
that's wrong in our government and we
need to fix that
now
speaking of the deep state there's a
report that's just come out it's from an
anonymous former intelligence officer
who now works for the pentagon who is
claiming that
vladimir putin
has a terminal illness
he's suffering from terminal bowel
cancer the evidence for this is that his
face is kind of puffy his face is
puffier than it was 20 years ago
apparently if you put on weight as you
age that's a sign that you are going to
die i guess you are going to die we're
all going to die someday but this is the
evidence that he's been during
chemotherapy or that he's on steroids
uh this is their other evidence from the
anonymous former intel officer in the
past we've seen him smile
but in 2022 there are a few pictures of
him looking happy
his look suggests he is in pain and our
people suggest his angry look is most
likely as a result of him being in agony
our people are confident he is ill he's
concerned about covet and he keeps the
staff at a distance
the fact that the autocrat in russia
as he is invading a sovereign nation
doesn't look so happy that's your
evidence
that
he's dying of cancer
maybe putin's dying of cancer maybe he's
not i don't know but the evidence
they're presenting is pretty weak to me
it sounds like
some nonsense to make the west feel good
to make us feel like there's going to be
an end to this thing and we don't need
to do anything about it but that's not
the case it sounds like happy thinking
it sounds like wish casting to me
and furthermore when they say well he's
he's acting irrationally because he's
got this disease or maybe he's got some
psychological disease who knows but he's
acting irrationally
that's a way to avoid strategic thinking
okay and it's why we've done so poorly
on this russia issue especially under
democrat administrations for 20 30 years
now
instead of just saying oh he's a crazy
person
how about you ask yourself what does
putin want
what does this look like from putin's
perspective what are putin's priors what
is he because i bet he sees the world a
lot differently than we do
what motivates him what makes him tick
how can we best
act
to protect ukraine to protect eastern
europe to protect the west in the united
states and to avoid war
and to reign in the ambitions of of
putin
because just calling him a madman and a
crazy person and just antagonizing him
without any effect without any purpose
that doesn't seem to be working that
seems bad for ukraine seems bad for
america seems bad for europe for what
for what to make us feel like we don't
need to do the hard work of actually
engaging what is motivating these people
it's a it's a silly report allegedly
coming out of the intelligence community
but we've seen a lot of silly reports
coming out of the ic for years and years
now the whole russia hoax came out of of
the ic
six years ago
there is some good news though
there is some good news coming out it's
like actually good way to end the show
especially on this day where we're
launching the fouchy unmasked series
which you can go check out at the daily
wire
jpmorgan chase major major bank is
ending its employer vaccine mandate
they sent a memo to employees observed
by bloomberg largest bank in the country
so they will stop the practice of
mandatory testing for workers without
the vaccine starting on april 4th they
will end the requirement for employees
to start to report covet 19 cases
masking will be optional for all staff
vaccinated or unvaccinated starting
immediately
why is this happening this is happening
because the people have pushed back this
is happening because the polls reflect
that this is not this there's no change
in the science the science is exactly
the same as it has always been
but the politics has changed the people
have pushed back
companies such as the daily wire not to
to our own horn have sued the federal
government have sued biden and won
the democrats are looking ahead to
november they realize this is not very
popular anthony fauci has been put in
the witness protection program and
people want to forget all the terrible
things he did to our country over the
last two years it actually even further
back than that
they're going
to retreat for a while but i think it's
a tactical retreat i think it's a
strategic retreat because in the long
run i don't think that the government
has given up any of this power i don't
think the
quasi-governmental
elites in the so-called private sector
have given up this power i think they
could bring it back
unless we just say no unless we say no
to this clown world we call a spade a
spade we don't pretend that men are
women we don't pretend that abortion is
healthcare we don't pretend that
criminals are victims we don't pretend
that we're living in the upside down we
still have a country we can still govern
ourselves we the people still have
rights if we don't let them slip through
our fingers i'm michael knowless the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show
stagflation may be coming according to
former clinton treasury secretary larry
summers but biden's gonna keep spending
all the money plus the russian assault
on ukraine continues and we may be
watching in real time the reshaping of
world financial markets all of that is
on today's bench shapiro give it a
listen